oftentimes I think we clutter our minds
and our lives and some people do that in
you know in manifests in actual things
like when they when people start
cluttering their houses and things like
that right
um it's the same thing with our mind and
the more you let in
the more you perhaps start to lose what
makes you you and there's never going to
be another you in this lifetime or in
this you know in in the history of
humankind so uh why not why not just you
know let yourself
um
be unproductive not do anything so that
you can listen to your inner voice to
tell you what it is that you need to
do or not do I think it's a really great
way to gain perspective on your life and
it's something that you need to
occasionally do in your life